it's Brandon drillo and leore Sanic on the line
inall for the Isles plays it up top a longrange
drive that's deflected wide of Darcy ker once
more in the cage for Washington pulock with a
heavy duty shot he scores from Deep 22 seconds
in starts with a ferocious Fork check by the
Islanders this line the Nelson line can really
get and down low you'll see it there's a little
pass by Nelson and there's the screen shot more
of John Carlson than anybody in front of the net
pulock from long range right past the goal tender
you have farari and palmari coming behind John and
that's what probably mixed ooshi tiptoes in who's
Nets off with a curling drag back to the midpoint
activates sandine slot pass down low deflected in
front a dangerous van reik there at the doorstep
sand for Milano too hot to handle Oshi settles
man Reams gets involved in that fiveman cycle
with ket off sandine moving halfway down the
Dasher back to point position the open Oshi in
front deflected Milano wonderful stop by barov and
acrobatically he hangs on for Washington was a gem
yeah TJ oi right to Bano in front he immediately
deflected it five pole and notice the goalies that
now go to butterflies quickly close up their
pads behind them and verom thought that went
through as did I but he squeezed just enough
to make that Nicholas had worn that a since
2010 Highlanders protecting the one-
nothing Advantage 920 to go in the
opening period Holstrom gets in there
with fashing fashing back to Holstrom he
scores that speed and more speed fashing and
Homen hook up stop on a two on0 theyve came
with speed between the two blue lines good passes
here here's the breakout pazo is going to win a
loose Puck it's going to come up and here come the
Islanders getting around the D and then passing it
through no chance for John Carlson to get back
on that play Hamman actel caught at the far Blue
Line locked up with pullup more
than halfway through regulation
with the aisles on top by two van re DY for
Milano short side attempt there for oi that
was blocked and the Isles will set sail back
through Center to the outside the familiar skating
stride of barel Sanden with him all the way to the
glass KET off pedals through Center finds Milano
for the entry Sunny's drop pass his Nets off
getting wide protecting unit enval and notice
they keep everything outside number one number
two they always seem to have numbers back the
capitals have not been able to create odd man
breaks Nelson closing in snap shot he scores
Brock Nelson I think he caught keer leaning a
little bit like he was going to pass to the far
post there was a man wide open there that's been
the key phrase here tonight there's a little
pass and there's that shot coming notice it
looked like keer was looking across there watch
Nelson he just spins and probably the hook by
Wilson coming back through that play awful little
bit at the far post there was a my man wide open
enough to force that offside there and not allow
that puck out of the Zone Conor MC Michel here
in this game playing quite a bit played over 12
and 1/2 minutes so far in the middle not made any
mistakes whatsoever in my books very diligent
with his details defensively cus little sneak
attack out of the corner keer was waiting at the
post alexe protus marching down the wing protus
with that long reach fested there by Romanov the
puck is on the skirt of the goal for a moment
they let the play continue through the officials
cik is chopping out of getting clear Carlson on
the give and go rotate for H octel Carlson to
the front that's easy pickings for barama yeah
Carlson didn't quite get it in his wheelhouse that
PO just a little bit in front of oh she dangles in
and fires broken up rebound there H octel lets
it go that was cancelled as well by Matt Martin
ketov stacking things up setting it for ooshi off
the head fake he lost the handle ketoff gets it
right back feeds the front deflected varlamov
there Point position ham octel fires [Applause]
score
that is a highlight reel pass from TJ ooshi on
his knees mam oel it's their fourth line their
identity line look at them keep pucks alive and
look at that pass and dexterity from TJ Oshi and
he definitely hit the goalie hit TJ TJ's got his
first of the year he should have more than that
for how well he's played in the volume of shots
he's had against the Isles in his career that's
his 18th goal in his 42nd game hovel will pick up
his second assist TJ makes it 3 to one it clicks
in off of it are they calling goalie interference
here New York Islanders are challenging the play
for goal tender interference yep that's what
they're calling one more look at it here's H
oel what a pass by TJ by playing knee hockey
in front of the neet off his shoulder off the
right side of TJ and into the net another look
and they are looking at it very closely at The
Penalty Box here to determine if that's goenda
appearence or not we share as many looks as we
can we also let you know that the officials
have additional replay angles afforded them
by The Situation Room there's the one I don't like
the first one he was allowed to reset let's hear
the call after video review it is determined that
there is goal tender interference on the play no
go extra man out there bet can h out feed it
down low wrap around P block followup chance
gamov great save on Strone with the goalie
pulled some chances right off the drop nice
work Carlson Obie down low to Oi right in front
just misses but the B MCM gets the draw back
sandine dragging the puck to the Dasher long
wrer goes wide ises able to send it off the
boards and out pal Mar doing the honors
1 minute 18 seconds left as protus will
clear in Anthony mantha golfs it on around
Martin there for New York high in the air
sandine kept it for a moment with 104 to play
Nelson fidgets it Loose oetkin there as we get
to the McNugget minutes of the third period
Darcy keer back between the pipes swinging a
Miss Nelson shake that one timer off the heel
of his blade 48 seconds remain capitals won't
have to wait long long to seek revenge against
the Isles these two teams meet again 9 days from
now at UBS Arena on Long Island we'll have it
for you on Monumental Sports Network and back
to back right on the road New Jersey Friday at
UBS Arena on Saturday night no easy assignment
nope final 20 ticks of the third Nelson
sends it down low All That Remains to be
settled involves Sean varlamov varlamov's
save percentage through three outings an
incredible north of 97 as he and the Isles
down Washington by the final count of three zip